What is radical feminist theory?
Have you ever wondered how deeply
embedded social structures shape our
lives?
Radical feminist theory takes a close
look at this question, focusing on the
role of patriarchy in women's
oppression.
This branch of feminist thought
identifies patriarchy as the main reason
for gender inequality.
Patriarchy is a system where men hold
primary power and dominate in areas like
politics, morality, and property
control.
From the viewpoint of social
anthropology, radical feminism examines
how cultural norms and institutions
support male dominance.
It argues that gender roles are not
natural or biologically determined, but
are socially constructed to maintain
male supremacy.
For instance, traditional roles that
label women as caregivers and men as
leaders restrict women's freedom and
reinforce unequal power dynamics.
A key idea in radical feminism is that
the personal is political.
This means that women's personal
experiences, such as domestic work and
experiences of violence, are influenced
by larger political and social systems.
Radical feminists believe that simply
seeking equal rights within existing
structures is not enough.
They advocate for a complete
transformation of patriarchal
institutions.
Radical feminist theory also critiques
compulsory heterosexuality.
This concept views heterosexual
relationships as a political institution
that enforces male dominance.
Traditional marriage often keeps women
economically and emotionally dependent
on men, limiting their independence.
Within radical feminism, there are
various approaches to dismantling
patriarchy.
Some activists call for abolishing
strict gender roles and embracing sexual
liberation.
Others celebrate feminine identity and
highlight women's unique strengths,
sometimes promoting lesbianism as an
alternative to traditional heterosexual
norms.
In social anthropology, radical feminist
theory is applied to analyze kinship
systems, marriage practices, and
gendered divisions of labor.
This helps to reveal how these
structures maintain patriarchal power.
Activism inspired by radical feminism
includes creating safe spaces for women,
campaigning against gender-based
violence, and advocating for family
structures that do not reinforce
traditional roles.
Radical feminist theory emphasizes the
social construction of gender and the
pervasive influence of patriarchy in
shaping societies.
It calls for a fundamental shift in
social relations to eliminate male
dominance and achieve gender equality.
By understanding these concepts, we can
better grasp how societal norms affect
our lives and work toward a more
equitable future.